they turned the ball over to louise
garcia yeah that last start was a very
good one in all kinds of ways not only
did he go out there and beat the dodgers
only allowing one earned run he struck
out seven of them also but that
highlighted number is the innings pitch
that's the first time we've seen him get
into that
sixth inning and actually complete it so
big step forward for the young man luis
garcia he is three-and-oh in his last
three starts pitching very well in this
rotation for dusty baker
in the year to center field mile straw
moves to his left
and puts it away for out number one
a lengthy winning streak very soon
a little tapper here first baseman
guriel will flip to the pitcher safe
garcia did not get the bag
and so verdugo ruled safe at first base
and the red sox have a man on not an
easy play at all guriel is going to have
to make this play and garcia is looking
for the bag
tried to make the play
popped up right by home played martin
maldonado loses the mask and puts it
away
count now two and two on boguards
swing and a miss luis garcia gets him
with the slider adam fishing out of the
zone
first strikeout of the night for luis
garrett richards four and three
383 era five and five lifetime against
houston
yeah he had to tough through a last five
and two-thirds last time out had some
control problems but pitched through it
the last two starts he's walked some
guys you know
tuvay loves to dig in before that first
ab they pack down that home plate area
and altuve likes to get a little
traction before his first swing
altuve hits one high and deep to left
field looking up verdugo good jose
altuve
home run and in back-to-back games
against the boston red sox he leads off
this one giving the astros a one-nothing
lead rosie altuve getting the head out
and lighting things up early
cut on and missed and he puts away a
tough hitter in bregman back-to-back
case
left-hand hitter from cuba
pounding ball off the pitcher's glove
and that's going to roll to the right
side of the infield and did get him
bang bang play but in time and after the
home run nice recovery by garrett
you want to be able to protect your
rotation with guys like javier and
garcia
this is miss on a fastball to get the
strike out of rafael devers to start
this inning
swing and a miss
that slider is being taken way off the
plate and the red sox hitters bogarts
and renfro has still gone after it
here's kyle tucker
hot shot fair ball past the diving
santana down the line
up against the 326 tucker's at it again
he's going to keep on motoring here's
bogarts to fire the tag got him debra's
getting the tag down tucker got a little
bit greedy
sharply hit and it's speared by altuve
well done going to his left hold your tk
then he hit her right where you thought
he would fordugo tries to chase down
altuve on his way to the dugout
maldonado of second el tuver first
3-2
bounty boy went for the bare hand
scooped up by gonzales got the out there
and turns two
i'll tell you what garrett richards has
been absolutely incredible getting out
of jams he really has he's not out of it
yet but what a big pitch
trying to hold up on an o2 pitch he goes
around
luis garcia picks up strikeout number
four
luis with a little dance
swing and a miss
strikeout number five for luis garcia he
has
struck out xander bogarts twice today
and mccormick can drive in a run without
a hit here and mccormick's been an rbi
machine really
and it's a high fly ball to right field
pretty well hit renfro all the way back
he's at the wall he's going to put it
away jordan alvarez will tag he will
score eely goes to third sac fly for
chas mccormick and the astros lead this
game two to nothing
so key first out for garcia brings up
marwyn gonzalez who's over one runner at
first goes swinging a little trickler
gonna be a play at first base and this
time he makes sure to get the bag as the
run comes in to score renfro into touch
home plate red sox on the board
fly ball
shallow left field down the line correa
and bregman it's alex bregman in foul
territory who puts it away for the final
out of the inning
one run on a couple of hits one man left
on base we're halfway home astros
leading two to one
red sox will have berdugo martinez beau
guards do up when we go to the sixth
inning
that one hammered right to third raffy
devers equal to the task and that'll do
it garrett richards has his fast inning
they go one two three
[Applause]
runner on the go swinging a miss devers
fires his hat his helmet down at home
plate luis garcia with a strikeout gets
through jd martinez xander bogarts and
now devers
pitch number 99 on the way to julie
guriel who's returned to the lineup this
evening
he's going to pop this one into right
field renfro right there
and once again richards gets it done he
faces only three men in the sixth inning
ground ball towards altuve makes the
play
marwin gonzalez retired luis garcia gets
through seven
first time in his career
he'll walk off the mound pounds that
fist into a glove with a two-to-one lead
runners on first and second nevertheless
straw for two ground ball towards short
boguards flips to gonzales for one the
wide throw is gonna score a run
astros take a three to one lead on a
wide throw by marwin gonzalez on a
potential double play ground ball correa
who's drawn 10 walks in his last five
games with a 3-0 count he's going to
force whitlock to give him a couple
pitches in his own i would imagine
can't do it
ball four
correa draws a walk to drive in a run
rbi number 28 for carlos correa with the
bases loaded walk
and it's now a 4-1 game
so now he'll face jordan alvarez
a little q shot off the end of the bet
bare-handed by devers to throw home not
in time
everybody safe the astros lead 5-1
on a little q-shot single by jordan
alvarez for an infield rbi hit
swing and a miss ryan stanek a one two
three ninth inning striking out two
getting hunter renfro for the final out
the astros have won the first two games
of this series
11-2 and tonight five to one